(loud whoosh)
- What's up, Believe Nation?
Today, I'm going to talk
about the seven ways
why most people don't become wealthy.
- [Distorted Voice] Nine.
Eight.
(techno music)
- So a lot of entrepreneurs
right in to me,
leave comments on the YouTube
channel, send me messages,
and say, "Evan, how do I get more wealthy?
"What are some of the steps?
"What are the things
I need to avoid doing?
"Because I haven't figured it out yet."
And so today, I'm going
to share the seven things
that are the reasons why you
haven't become wealthy yet.
(synthesizer music)
Number one is you have the wrong mindset.
This is super important.
Whether you believe you can
or you can't, you're right.
There's always two sides of the coin.
The glass is half empty and is half full.
You're both right.
Whatever side you come on,
you're going to be right.
How do you look at new
problems and new opportunities?
Do you see them as a problem
or do you see them as an opportunity?
Whenever people come up
with a new business idea,
you're going to have some
people who will tell you
all the reasons why it can work out,
and here's a market that you can go to
and here's how to make it work,
and you're going to have the other people
who come to you and say all the reasons
why it's not going to work out,
all the immediate problems
that are going to come in,
why you're never going to make it work.
And the thing is, they're both right,
because with any new idea,
there's going to be all these problems
and there's going to be lots
of opportunity, as well.
And so these people are the ones
who are going to get wealthy.
These people are going to be the ones
who go out and have an impact.
These people are the ones who
go out and change the world.
And these people are the ones
who just never do anything,
who are just pessimistic and
sit on the couch and complain
and blame other people for why
they're not more successful.
So which camp do you fall into?
Are you part of the group that believes
that anything is possible,
that when you see an opportunity,
you're positive and optimistic
that you can go out and do it?
Or are you part of the ones who are afraid
and are limiting and complain
and blame other people?
Because the mindset is
the most important thing.
You get that right, and
it's not just saying it,
it's not just saying, "Yeah, I can do it,"
it's believing it, like
this is going to happen.
Do you actually believe
that you are worthy?
Do you actually believe that
you are going to become a
wealthy, successful person?
'Cause if you don't,
you're going to stay here.
You're just going to think about
all the reasons why you can't do it,
and if you're focusing
on why you can't do it,
then you're never going to get there.
So fix your mindset.
(synthesizer music)
Number two is a poor environment,
and by poor, I don't just mean bad.
By poor, I also mean
with wealth, like poor,
like people have a no
money kind of mindset,
an attitude, belief system.
Look at the people around you.
Don't just look at, "Do they have money?"
but, "Do they have a rich mindset?"
Do they have an abundant mindset?
Do they have that positive mindset?
If you are only around the
people in that last example
where we shared the positive people,
the people who see the opportunity,
and the negative people who
just see all the problems,
if you're just hanging around the people
who just see problems all the time,
then guess what's going to happen to you?
It's going to be really hard
to be that positive person
when you're just surrounded by negativity.
And it's not just the people in your life.
It's your habits.
It's your routine.
It's your environment.
Like I walk into this every
day and I get inspired,
and I want to think bigger.
It forces me to think bigger
and push my comfort zone.
I think about Alex,
who's helped me out at
Toronto Dance Salsa--
- Hi.
Hey there.
How are you?
- And his morning routine
used to be wake up
and look at some 9GAG photos,
which I hadn't even heard
of before, what 9GAG was,
but it's jokes and pranks and tricks
and just things that make you laugh,
and he substituted that on his own
now by reading leadership articles,
'cause he wants to be
a better leader, badly.
He wants to lead the eight
instructors that we have
and the 40 to 50 helpers that we have
and help them make a bigger impact.
He desperately wants that,
and so switching that habit
from looking at some jokes
to now developing a leadership mindset
changed his environment,
changed his perspectives,
gives him more motivation,
encouragement, optimism,
going from that poor mindset
to an abundant positive one.
And so I challenge you
to look at your habits,
look at your routine.
Not just the people around
you and not just blaming them,
blaming your parents
and blaming your friends
and blame, blame, blame, blame, blame.
What are you going to do about it?
'Cause there's a lot that you can control.
You're just going to
look at all the things
that is outside your control,
all these people around you.
Great, seek out new people.
Go to events where your kind
of people are hanging out.
Watch videos where you're
surrounded by these people
that fill up your head.
Read books that motivate and inspire you.
Look at every single habit
that you have and ask yourself,
the things that you are doing,
is it from a poor mindset?
Is this making you poor,
keeping you where you are,
or is it filling you up and
making you richer and wealthier?
And not just in a financial
sense, as a person.
You are what you consistently do.
So what are you consistently doing?
If somebody is healthy, they
can have a chocolate bar.
They can nosh down on an Oh Henry
or Reese's Pieces once in a while.
It's not going to impact them.
It's not going to be a huge
negative spike for them.
But if you're eating chocolate bars
every single day five times a day,
you're going to be unhealthy.
And if you're doing that every day
and you have one good day and
you fall back to your pattern,
you're going to stay unhealthy.
You are what you consistently do.
So what are you consistently doing?
And how can you tweak those habits
to escape the poor mindset
and have a wealthy one?
(synthesizer music)
Number three is the lack of action.
So it's great to have amazing
ideas for what you want to do,
amazing ideas for things
that could happen.
And then what ends up happening?
Are you actually taking the action,
or are you just seeing other people
go out and make lots of money
and have a big impact off of your idea?
You can't blame them.
You can only blame yourself.
If you have an idea to
try and do something
that you think is going to have an impact
that will make you wealthy
in every sense of the word,
then you got to go and do it.
'Cause a lot of people are so afraid
that their idea just dies within them.
The idea dies with them!
You had greatness inside you
to go out and have a huge impact,
be legendary, have your
grandkids look up to you
as one of the most influential
people in their lives,
and you failed everybody
because you just kept it in here
because you were too afraid
to go out and do something.
People don't become wealthy
because they don't act
on their great ideas.
You got to act, and
again, consistently act.
You are what you consistently do.
So are you consistently
acting every single day
to move that idea a little
bit further forward?
Or do you get a little bit of negativity
and then you stop and you quit,
and you come back a little
bit, and then you quit again?
Consistency.
You need to be prolific.
Be prolific in the pursuit of your goal.
Daily action.
Don't stop.
(synthesizer music)
Reason number four why you
are not becoming wealthy
is you're trying to do
everything yourself.
The most successful people, the
wealthiest people understand
that other people are a
great resource for them.
And this was one of the biggest mistakes
I made early on in my first company.
I was trying to do everything myself.
And so understanding that,
whether you can afford
to bring somebody on or not is an option,
like the first guy I hired
was for one hour a day.
I didn't have the budget to go out
and have a full time salary for somebody.
It was one hour a day
that freed up my time
to go do more work, higher leverage work,
work I enjoyed more.
But also, getting other people involved
even on a volunteer
basis, friends, family,
people that you've met.
When I first started my YouTube channel,
I made a deal with a friend of mine,
Mark Drager from Phanta Media,
who's actually in the book,
his one word is extraordinary,
and he came in and shot some videos
out of my office at the time,
and that's how I started
my YouTube channel.
My future videos, some of them
I borrowed cameras from my friends.
Not just locking yourself
in your own world
and expecting to do everything yourself
and involving more people.
Understanding what it is
that you are great at,
that you have Michael Jordan
level genius talent at,
what is that, and spending as
much time there as possible.
And eliminate a lot of the other work
and trying to get other people involved
to cover your weaknesses.
'Cause what ends up happening,
the poor mindset is,
"I'm going to do everything myself,
"and I'm going to spend
two percent of my time
"on the genius level talent
"that I'm the best in the world at
"and 98 percent of my time doing the crap,
"doing the work that I'm not
great at that has to get done
"because I feel like I've
got to do it all myself."
And so it's being resourceful.
You might think, "Yeah, that's great.
"If I had a bunch of money,
"I would go out and hire people
and it would get it done."
You're missing the point.
If that's what you're thinking,
you're already starting
with the poor mindset.
You're missing the point.
It's not about going out to get the money
to hire the people.
It's about being
resourceful and finding ways
that you can get those people to help you
with you giving them something back
that doesn't have to be monetary.
They may help you just because
they want to be around you,
'cause they like you
or they want to support what you're doing.
They may help you
because they love the
mission that you're on
and they want to be a part of it.
At Toronto Dance Salsa, we've
got 50 people who volunteer,
who help, who are higher level students
and come to the lower level classes
to give their advice and experience.
They do it for free because
they want to give back,
because we've created a great environment
for them to give back.
And so there's people who
would want to help you
if you just expand your
thinking to figure out,
where do I need help,
and who can I ask for it?
You can't do this alone.
(synthesizer music)
Number five is you don't model success,
and again, I had this problem
when I first started my business.
I felt like I had to come up
with all the ideas myself.
I felt like everything that
we did, every new execution,
had to come from within here.
And it almost sunk our business.
It made me say, "I quit," to my partner.
And I came back the next
day and I didn't quit
'cause it was too important
to me to continue.
But the thing that broke through,
that helped my company
take off, was me realizing
that I'm not the first
guy to try to do this.
Somebody else has already
figured out the model.
And in software, it was
the industry I was in,
I looked at Bill Gates.
Now, I sold biotech software.
Bill Gates's first software
product wasn't biotech,
but I could still learn
how he made it work for him
and apply it to my business,
and that was the start of the change.
That was getting us to the next step.
And so whatever problem you have,
whatever problem you're facing right now,
somebody has already solved it.
Many people have already solved it.
And so look into their success,
understanding what they did to solve it,
and applying it to your business
will dramatically improve the chance
of you becoming successful and wealthy
in every sense of the word.
So it's great to come
up with ideas yourself.
I'm not saying just copy everybody else.
It's great to add your own creativity,
but you don't need to come up with
every single idea yourself.
Research who has done it, learn from them,
apply their strategies to
make your business a success,
and it will be.
(synthesizer music)
Number six is you don't
provide enough value.
This is just the basics of business.
If you want to make money, money
is only an exchange of value.
If you want to have an impact,
it's going to come from exchanging value.
So does your product or service
actually provide enough
value to your customers?
And, I wouldn't blame your marketing
or blame something else
that's outside your control.
You have the control.
At Toronto Dance Salsa,
a lot of our business
comes from word of mouth marketing,
because we provide a great product
and great experience
that people really enjoy
and they want to tell
their friends about it.
In this business,
and looking at the YouTube
videos as an example,
the videos are good, right?
I get traffic.
I get an audience.
We have half a million plus subscribers.
That's great.
And I deserve that.
But I also don't deserve to
be at two million subscribers
because my videos aren't good enough yet.
So I'm not providing
you with enough value.
I'm not providing you with enough value
that you are off instantly
sharing this video.
Some of you are.
Some of you take my video
and you tweet it out
and you link it up on Instagram
and you tell all your friends about it,
and I really appreciate that.
But for a lot of you, you don't.
A lot of you aren't even
watching this video.
You didn't even make it this far.
And I'm not blaming you.
I'm blaming me.
I got to get better.
I got to pick better topics.
I got to be better on camera.
I need to offer better points.
I need to give you more tangible advice.
I need you to get results
from watching these videos.
If you got tremendous results
from watching these videos,
then you would go off
and tell your friends
and my audience would grow a lot faster.
So I am offering some value.
It's how I got here.
It's not that my channel sucks.
It's great.
But it could always be better.
And so instead of blaming the market
or blaming the economy
or blaming the president
or blaming interest rates
or blaming whatever,
the wealthy, successful
entrepreneurs take responsibility.
They blame themselves, and they look at,
how can I do better?
'Cause it's inside your control.
And so if you add more value
to the product or service
that you're providing,
you're going to get better results.
(synthesizer music)
And the number seven reason why
most people don't become wealthy
is because they make
wealth their only goal.
If you look at the people
who've had tremendous success,
the people behind me on the wall,
the people who you can look up to,
go to the Forbes list of the
richest people in the world,
money was never the number one goal.
Having financial wealth was
never the number one goal.
Now, it's important.
Money is important.
Unless you're a charity, which
still, money is important
because you need money
to survive and keep going
and pay for people's salaries.
Money is important, so I'm
not saying forget about money.
But money is number two.
There has to be something above
money for you to keep going,
because whatever you get into,
if you want to be the best as it,
if you want to have a lot of success,
you want to get to that point
where you're providing so much value
that you're the number one person,
it's going to be a lot of work.
It's going to be a lot of crap.
It's going to be a lot
of sucking at the start.
You don't just coast
your way to number one.
You work.
You grind.
You hustle your way to number one.
You put in the extra practice
more than anybody else is doing.
You make more videos than
anybody else is doing.
You work hard on your craft
more than anybody else is doing.
The only thing that gets you going
is an absolute passion for
the work that you're doing.
There has to be something above money,
'cause if money is you're only goal,
you're going to quit as
soon as it gets hard.
Money will only keep
you going for so long,
and then you're going to quit.
And so if money is your goal,
you can get there, you'll make some money,
but you're never going to
be really, really wealthy.
You're never going to get to that point.
You're never going to be one
of the greatest of all time
because you're chasing the wrong thing.
You can only force yourself
to do something that you hate
for so long before you quit.
You'll move on.
You don't want to deal
with this crap anymore.
The people who have
success, they love the crap.
It's not crap for them.
That's the difference.
You would look at my schedule
and what I do on YouTube
and think, "That is so much crap.
"I could never do that."
And that's why I'm winning.
And if I looked at your schedule,
if I looked at his schedule,
his schedule, his schedule,
I would be like, "That's nuts.
"I couldn't do that."
And so you have to have the
thing that's above money.
And understanding what
your one word can help.
Figuring out what your passion
is absolutely important.
Money is number two.
This is insulting in England.
One of you guys told me that.
Money is number two.
There has to be something more important.
So that's my take on the seven reasons
why most people don't become wealthy.
I'd love to know, what do you guys think?
What point resonated the most with you?
What can you take from this video
and immediately apply to
your life or your business?
Did I miss an eight, nine, 10
that you guys want to add to the list?
Leave it down in the comments below.
I'm going to join in the discussion.
I also want to give a
quick shoutout to Ujjwal.
I hope I pronounced that okay.
Thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, and making that picture,
and putting me in the seal on the side.
That was pretty cool.
Thank you so much for your love.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love.
I'll see you soon.
(loud whoosh)